you know there's there's one very
tangible practical way
that left-wing policies are uh are
disrupting people right now that
left-wing fantasies
are hurting people's real lives
what's going on in texas you uh if
you're watching this show on video
you'll see that i'm not in my usual
studio i'm actually at home we've had
snow days
at the daily wire because there's a big
storm in tennessee and the roads are icy
and
they don't want people to come in okay
that's fine uh this is really
affecting texas all this crazy weather
texas is getting hit with a horrible
winter storm
and compounding that problem
there are rolling blackouts all
throughout the state but the cause of
the blackouts is not just the weather
it's also bad left-wing policies
the overall power input of texas has
declined
pretty significantly after half of the
state's
wind turbines were frozen in a winter
storm over the weekend
parts of texas are now down to zero
degrees fahrenheit
texans are freezing right now more than
two million homes and businesses
have experienced power outages because
the wind turbines froze
why is texas which is you know
basically just a state made of oil
made of fossil fuels why are they
relying on wind turbines
because radical environmentalists
are so afraid of the sun monster that
they say
is going to destroy the world through
global warming
what what do they say 12 years aoc says
and prince charles said 18 months but he
said it like two years ago so i guess
the world is over already
they're so afraid that global warming is
going to destroy the world that they
reordered texas
texas energy policies and now texans are
freezing
we all it's become sort of cliched even
say this we could all use a little
global warming right now it's pretty
chilly
well michael weather isn't climate
except when it's convenient for us to
say that weather is climate well the
weather conditions have nothing to do
with the climate okay i don't want to
relitigate the climate issue
we'll talk about that some other time
i'm just pointing to the political issue
here
the fantasy of imminent armageddon
because of the sun monster
is leading to insane policies that are
now by the way the way to rectify these
wind turbine issues
is to pour chemicals made with fossil
fuels from
aircraft made from fossil fuels on wind
turbines also made from fossil fuels
you know probably not really great for
the environment to make up
for these policies that were put forward
because
the left is living in a fantasy that is
having very
unpleasant effects in reality if you
enjoyed that break from disinformation
historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you